[Music]
welcome to best life 30 your 30 day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself
you can just watch this video or if you
want to sign up for the entire series
for free and get the bonus companion
worksheets that go with this video
check the link in the description below
alright today is day two and we're gonna
learn how to find our motivation
i feel like most people in their lives
are
being allowed to live small you're
allowed to live a small
life everyone around you would like you
to live small just do this you're good
at that man take it easy chill when's
enough enough
like come on brother you know where we
all these messages you get is basically
saying hey man
live small yeah life's not a big deal
live small enjoy it chill smoke a little
weed do whatever you want to want right
like it's just this
get by thing in life and there's got to
be some people go no
no you're supposed to do something great
with your life you were put here for a
purpose
your way the way you were born the way
you were raised
your background your experiences your
giftedness
all prepared you in your way for right
now
and you're supposed to do something
great with your life you weren't born
here to be average and ordinary and
there's all this messaging that you're
averaging ordinary
and you're averaging because you belong
there and it's probably someone else's
fault you're averaging ordinary too i'm
like no it's your life
you're in control it's no one else's
fault and you're supposed to do
something
magnificent that's the consciousness
aspect the last
thousand years on earth doing something
great has been reserved to this one
little group of people
one percent of the population they're
supposed to do something great
they're supposed to live their dreams
we're supposed to watch them cheer for
them
wear their jersey watch their award show
comment on their posts clean their
houses
right feed them in their restaurants no
the fact of the matter is
you can do those things you can change
your life and i'm sick and tired of this
hero worship you live small cheer for
everybody else who lives big
no if you're a schoolteacher be the best
damn schoolteacher change the world by
those little lives you're affecting
if you're on social media change the
world play big
you will never do it wrong if your
decision is to do the bigger thing than
the smaller thing
that's what i would tell you stop
playing small stop thinking small and
don't let anybody tell you you should be
small
here's the hard truth about getting
great
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness
to accept that you're not yet good
enough it takes the ability
to stare at the places that you know
that you're weak to really look at those
things and not
let it affect your sense of self-esteem
and not let it affect your sense of
self-worth so that you can still
get the momentum going but you have to
understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible and as henry
cartier-bresson said
your first ten thousand photographs are
your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work
and face how inadequate they are and
really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft
greatness is a process greatness
is a habit greatness is the little
things that you do
every day over time going out every day
unafraid of whether or not this is one
of the ten
thousand terrible things that you're
gonna do it's being unafraid to make
those mistakes
is being unafraid that you're not yet
great and as marianne radmaker said
courage doesn't always roar sometimes
courage is the quiet voice at the end of
the day saying
i will try again tomorrow and that's it
if you want to be great that's what you
have to do you've got to get up again
tomorrow
you've got to be willing to face another
day you've got to be willing to accept
that you've got to get through the bad
ideas
before you can get to the good you've
got to understand that you have to start
as an apprentice
you have to start as a person going and
getting t and you have to accept
that that's the job that you should be
playing that you should be working for
somebody else you should be looking up
to somebody else's seeing
what they can teach you because what you
know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10
000 bad photographs that you need to get
through to ultimately achieve
greatness and if you make the
catastrophic error that's so
many make to try to tell the world that
you're extraordinary today
to try to get the world to follow you
and look up to you and think that you're
something
today because the people that really win
are the ones that invest
today the ones that listen today
the ones that spend every ounce of their
energy
amassing mastery getting better
every day working their asses off to
improve their skill set to relentlessly
look at the things that they're not
doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really
find greatness those are the people that
we remember
so if you want to be remembered if you
want to achieve
real greatness you just need to have the
courage to show up
every day and take another swing
take another photo try another task
do something that scares you and do
those little things
over and over and over
until you win if you're gonna do what
you say you're gonna do be what you say
you're gonna be
you're gonna have to lie me out that
gazelle stop i'm trying to tell you
you're a gazelle you're gonna come up
short you're a gazelle
you're not always gonna get what you
want out of life you a gazelle
it's gonna be you're gonna have an
average experience you're a student i
need you in lion mode
you're a teacher i need you in line mode
you an entrepreneur i need you in line
mode
you trying to lose weight lying mo you
can't do
nothing significant in gazelle mode
nothing
nothing impressive happens in gazelle
mode nothing happens when you run it
nothing happened in run mode give up
mode quit mode
scared mode fearful mode nothing happens
everything happened in line mode like
i'm coming to get you
i love y'all i've seen the one where the
lioness is kind of sitting there
and she double-dutching and all the
beast is running by
and they just keep going and she just in
preparation mode
and out of nowhere there is no no music
no
no preparation you just see my man come
out of nowhere and just
boom boom grab one boom
boom rip your heart out that's lion mode
and you gotta get to a place
where you start executing somebody just
helped me out
last year the greatest news in the nba
the greatest story in the nba last year
was what greatest story
told in the nba last year all season was
what
kevin durant left go to golden state
durant like i'm out i don't know where
y'all come from
but that hurt hard because they supposed
to be boys
look at this picture for a minute
because that's why if you're going to be
successful
this is where i need you to go right
here what a pig this was the one
where you play your boy first game you
when your homie was cool
right and this is where you emotionally
cut it
this is when you cut my man this is when
you see my man and he's trying to be
cool he's trying to act like he
leave you high and dry he try to act
like the goals and the dreams y'all have
this the one where he clapping and you
look my man in his face and say
you did to me and that's why most of you
will never be successful
because there's some stuff in your past
you keep holding on to and you got to
get to a point when you're ready to
grind and you're ready to get to the
next level you look at people you used
to be close to and say
you did to me you did
42 triple doubles we shouldn't even be
talking about the mvp
ain't nobody else even if somebody else
make it close to the mvp
the nba is rigged and i'm through with
them
they saw my man if you get in the season
i'm coming i'm from a hot octagon
they said if he keep doing that all
season what's going to happen
he said he keep running himself like
that he's going to burn out
my man ain't burnt out he don't look
like he ain't close to burnout
but you know why they said it because
they can't operate on that level
for that long so people will try to put
their limitations on you
i can i can do six gigs i can do seven
we can leave here tonight you can take
me to a church i'll give you another
hour you can't do it
don't put your limitations on me i'm
dead to your limitation
your limitations don't exist in my world
those are your limitations keep them
go home watch them on tv go home read
the newspaper about go home and look in
the mirror
go home call your homeboy and y'all talk
about your limitations i ain't got no
i get off the plane from going to dubai
and get on the ground
and i hit it and some of y'all hold on
to stuff you shouldn't be holding on to
it should be dead to you dog gonna go do
a funeral if you need to get rid of that
jump like bury it do whatever you got to
do
but it's weighing you down it's killing
you every day you're waking up thinking
about it you shouldn't be thinking about
it no more it should be dead to you
move on and move towards your greatness
i forget those things
which are behind and i press i press
towards the thing
i press i don't got time for that no
more there's nothing personal
i ain't got nothing against you i don't
hate you but i
love me what if i told you this was the
last monday morning of your life
what if i told you you died this week
would you complain about your crap job
or that test you don't want to take i
doubt it you would go much higher level
thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding
that if you're not pumped right now if
you're begrudging what you're about to
do
if you're if you're not looking forward
to it look i respect practicality
you got to go through school because
your parents want to you got to pay your
rent
you got student loans i get it but
please recognize the world we're living
in
we're living in a world where there's so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created
way more opportunity for all of us way
more i mean look
you might not even be alive like your
mom and dad could have had sex like
three minutes later and you wouldn't
even exist and you're complaining
you could have ended up being a bus a
tree i just don't get the mentality of
being head down sad
on a monday morning i'm gonna make
monday morning my
i'm gonna make you saturday monday
morning that's what i want to do every
morning
and that's what i want from you please
take a step back
and think about how awesome it actually
is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way
because you were lucky enough to be born
during this
era i didn't for several years i gave
myself a way out
when you were 300. now it's 300 pounds
when i was
all the way up to i was 24 years old i
would
climb a mountain i fall back down i
start climbing i fall back down for the
first 24 years of my life
i went to my first tell week my second
hell week and then my third whole week
came in seal training
and the co captain bowen looked at me
i'm on crutches i'm all jacked up he
says hey
this is your last time you're gonna go
through buds
this is it i had several stress
fractures
i had double pneumonia i was jacked up
and he gave me a few months to heal
he said this is your last time going
through i shouldn't even let you go back
through
wow i started navy seal training with
stress fractures
stress fractures that's hard to finish
stress fractures
starting the hardest training argument
in the world with stress fractures
this is when i started to not put a cap
on the
body if the mind is there every morning
i wake up at 3 30 morning 4 o'clock in
the morning
go to my dive cage go in there before
anybody saw me
i'd get duct tape and i would tape from
my forefoot
all the way up to the middle of my calf
and i would put two black socks on
and so i ran not using the pivot oh my
gosh
and i ran my hip flexors so for the
first 45 minutes to an hour
i was in absolute excruciating pain
but what motivated me through that whole
process
was the fact that this kid
came from that i'm in the hardest
training in the world
in the worst shape of my entire life
what if i can graduate amongst these
studs wow
all these guys around me are studs
they're stallions they're gladiators in
my class they're all healthy
most of them they're not broken like
this they may have some
you know everybody's sick going down
training but if i could graduate
it would change everything for me if i
could start the hardest chain in the
world
broken and graduate so my mind
fed off of that you are now from the
weakest man you're now the hardest man
to ever
live if you can do this if you can do
this
life is one big mind game yeah and
you're playing it with yourself
is it true i don't care
it got me through the hardest training
starting out broken
where most people quit i just started
wow and when you take that mindset and
you learn to flip that around
that's what made me powerful and my body
followed
and three months later my stress
fractures
were healed by running on them
[Music]
when i was a kid he's always visualized
stadiums and like
even when i was playing football i'd
kick the ball against the wall and i'd
pretend i scored a goal and i'd run off
and i'd be
raising my hand and visualizing a arena
full of fans
that was something i done as a kid out
on my own i like
just running around kicking the ball i
always had these visions of something
but i just didn't know what it was and
then i suppose when i came to this of
these events
and i started training and then came to
an event i was like okay
this is it this is this is what i'm
gonna do and then
now i'm doing it did you ever have let's
call it a normal job
connor a nine to five yeah because
the irish thing is the games were traded
straight away i was no different as soon
as
i finished school i was always getting
pestered what are you doing with your
life you know they're still on that
um they didn't know what it was they
didn't know what
mma was they know what none of this they
didn't know i could make a career as far
as they were considering man that i'm
talking about as far as they were
concerned i was just getting into a cage
and fighting with some other guy
they didn't know nothing about it no one
did really but i knew you know what i
mean i knew
but uh and then i got i ended up getting
a trade just to keep them quiet cause
there's a lot of fights with me dialogue
what trade did you get i ended up
getting a
trade as a plumber how bad was that
diploma
yeah horrendous were you actually in the
trenches
i mean it was an industrial pool so i'd
be like building this
it'd be like diploma that would be
needed in a place like this
six o'clock in the morning and i'm not
waiting i used to have to
walk for about an hour to get to them to
get their motorway and then i'd stand on
the edge of the motorway and wait for a
bloke to drive boy
so he'd give me a lift and then the
motorway was like getting them
renovation at the time so take me two
hours two and a half hours to get to the
places out in the country
then i'd be there for 10 hours walking
and i was at first year so it was the
worst of the war ceremonies only
beginning
then two hours to get back in the
traffic again it was just a horrible
horrible time and i was like you know
what
i don't want to do this and then i just
left i lasted 18 18 months still
but it was tough you know just it wasn't
it wasn't the life of me you know
and then john said because i was
training with john as well at the time
and then john got on touch and says i
have a show i'm on the show i'd like to
fight honey
and then that was it i just packed it in
didn't show up my dad used to come in
and punch the head on me and
like try and drag me out of bed and i
just wouldn't go and normally i hadn't
uploaded for a good few years when i'm
overabout and
and that was it i just packed it in quit
and then focused on training
and that's i knew i knew i knew what was
going to happen i knew i was going to
get here
they didn't there's a lot of stressful
years a lot of tough times
but i proved them wrong i proved myself
right
but everything i do in my life is
is related to this i don't do nothing
else if it's not got to deal with
fine i don't mean and that that is why
you know i mean to be true
that's really all you've got to do is
show up is that not
unhealthy um i don't know
do i look unhealthy take a look at this
physique i'm in phenomenal shape
in body and mind to me what's unhealthy
is living an unhealthy life
to me what's unhealthy is getting up and
going through the same day every day i
like nine to five in an officer in it
and that that's unhealthy that beats
your mind
i don't i don't work i i love what i do
and that's why i'm doing what i love you
know what i mean that's why that's why
it's become a career for me because i
love it
i love what i do nobody's ever had to
motivate me
in my whole life
nobody ever had to motivate steve jobs
in his whole life
nobody ever had to motivate henry ford
the first in his whole life
and i can go down the list of every
single
one
my experience for the people that are
the most successful
the hall of famers the billionaires that
i've made like god
out of clay i didn't have to motivate
them
so what does that tell you about forget
this room
let's say that you're an anomaly this
room
we know that's a lie but i'm going to
sound like the gurus
the guys that you followed here for and
lie to you a little
we know you don't need motivation but
what about those poor
that do need motivation what did that
say about them
forget about it next
nobody ever my my kids uh our kids hate
hearing this story but one of the uh
still one of the guys that i work for
on wall street for wall street firm
who says he gave me my first legitimate
job
um tells uh the kids and he's the
godfather to one of our children
he says um we used to have to have the
security guards drag your father from
the office
and make him go home to sleep after five
six days
straight the security guards dragged me
from the
office
my kids hate hearing that
i used to take a sponge bath
um in the men's room
and have my secretary go buy me a new
shirt every day
and i used to have a proclivity of
dropping [ __ ] on my tie so i just have
to buy a lot of ties too
so then i realized if you buy dark ties
it doesn't show
you don't have to buy as many times but
they had to drag me out of the office
i should be able to go two three days
with no sleep
and i drank like i drank in all night
guys if you don't think you can [ __ ] all
night guess what you can't [ __ ] all
night
qla is exactly the same
i can tell no i can tell not hardly
anybody in this room ever
all night but nobody's ever had to
tune me up to get me to work hard i've
always wanted a six-pack and i don't
have it
and i don't know and i've never had it
and
when i i finally stopped complaining
about it
when i got honest about what it was
going to require
oh i'm dead serious dead serious about
this
at my you know at 49
with my affinity for alcohol and my love
of carbs
and my taste for exercise
i have a small problem on my hands if i
want a six-pack
so if you were to go forward right and
think okay well if a year from now i had
a six-pack
what would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that
and then you can stop beating yourself
up for the [ __ ] you never intend on
doing
what i realized is i can spend four
minutes a day
in a hotel room or in my bedroom doing
planks and my arms look great and
everybody else will think the rest of my
body's in shape
we're good yes
it looks like a charm so you might want
to get honest with yourself
like instead of doing this i don't want
to be a millionaire
do you really because you can make
it happen you actually can look at all
the idiots that are making money you can
make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay
if i'm able to put
a thousand dollars a month against my
debt i'm able to
make x amount of dollars a month i'm
able to put x amount of dollars in
savings what do i need to be doing a
year from now to make that happen
and what are those habits that are there
a year from now
that i don't have right now and then
roll yourself back to this moment just
like i explained with exercise
do i actually not want to have a
manhattan tonight nope
did i want to go to the gym today nope
did i i would am i am i willing to not
eat what i ate for
nope am i willing i did my four minutes
my arms are looking really good
but so bring it back and then you will
have the formula for pivoting
at any moment you time travel forward a
year
you investigate the patterns that you
have that are giving you the result that
you want and then you back your ass up
to right here right now
and you decide am i willing to do this
now if i'm willing
then 54321 through all the excuses that
are going to be there when you're trying
to override your operating system
that's how you do it or you have the
reality check like i had which is oh
[ __ ] i just like the [ __ ]
i don't intend on changing so why don't
we get this off the plate
and let's focus on the things that i am
actually committed to
rome wasn't built in a day
we all know that everyone's hears that
but rome also didn't fall apart
overnight either
it took hundreds of years for rome to
reach its peak
but it also took time hundreds of years
for rome to decay and fall apart
and that is representative
of life because you don't achieve
worthwhile goals quickly or
easily they take time
they take struggle they take
relentless pursuit day in
and day out that's what it takes
but also things don't usually
fall apart quickly either
at least at first it's it's a slow
process a little slip here
a little set back over there a little
wearing down of discipline
and will over time
that's the thing success and failure
are generally slow processes
either slowly building things up
[Music]
or gradually tearing them down
and that's why i say you've got to pay
attention
you have to watch you have to watch
every single second
because those seconds
they turn into minutes and minutes
turn into hours and hours turn into days
and days turn in to years
and so that second
that second that just went by
that counted
and so did that second and so did that
one
and in those precious seconds
you were either building
or you were decaying you were either
[Music]
gaining ground
[Music]
or you were losing ground
in that second
and in every second
every second counts
so make
every second
count you know i don't really like the
word inspiration
i like the word motivation because i
think
the working part always matters more
than the inspiration part
work is always more important than the
idea and as far as motivation
uh you know i'm motivated by everything
around me i'm motivated by my kid i'm
motivated by
by other people's work i'm motivated by
the people that i work with
um i'm like a sponge i absorb the
motivation to do my work from everything
around me
most people procrastinate because they
don't feel confident that the what
they're doing really motivates them
if it really motivates motivated you it
would you wouldn't procrastinate
it's like a 14 year old kid that the mom
and dad can't get the kid to do anything
but the kids motivated to play video
games kid will ride his bike across town
to buy a video game and come back like
so there's motivation there the parents
just don't know how to find it
and as you grow you have to know how to
find deep within yourself that
motivation and once you have motivation
you have no problem with procrastination
the turning point for me was
was that it was halloween last year
and i'd never suffered any more anxiety
attacks or anything
since about mid to late summer
that year live 17.
but i was still drinking and still going
out partying and whatever i didn't value
nothing at all
but every time i got drunk i'd come home
and i'd say right i'm
starting training in the morning regain
mission i'm going to be the heavyweight
champion of the world again
you watch you were 400 pounds 400 pounds
i was the man who called wolf a thousand
times
phone all my friends up phone chain i'm
get them all going come on
we're going to do it monday monday he'd
come no i do not want to box anymore
finished
turning point was i went out halloween
dressed as a
skeleton in a fancy dress party i went
out about nine o'clock and expected to
stay out all night and get
smashed i had one drink
i looked around me and i thought what am
i doing i said to myself you're telling
me
that you'd rather be here with a load of
kids half your age because i feel like
the old person now when i go out i'm 30.
they're all 18 and like i know it's 21
over here but over almost
sure 18 they're all at 18 19 20 21.
and i'm i'm like the old guy in the
disco bopping around this is it you
traded
having all them achievements for what
and i knew i couldn't do it on my own i
just knew it
i couldn't do it i said so many times i
was going to do it and believed i was
going to do it and the night
the next day come i didn't have no
motivation to do it
that's another thing that mental health
will give you no zero motivation to do
anything
zero motivation to have a shave zero to
brush your teeth even have a shower
nothing i got back that night
i mean i thought i was drunk i come home
early she says oh you're home early
i said yeah i said i've had enough for
this life i said tomorrow
i said i start to turn my life around
and this was halloween night
yeah 2017. she said yeah yeah i've heard
it all before because i'm the man who
cried wolf
a thousand times i said i promise you
i said i'm gonna do it i'm definitely
going to do it
and um nobody believed me
but i knew i had a smile on my face
twinkling my eye and i knew i had to get
that weight off by the way at this time
i was looking at a 12-year ban
i'd failed two drugs tests for cocaine
because all the time i was out i was
still doing random drugs tests
so i had cocaine in my system on two
times occasions
the british boxing border controller
suspended me license
i was deemed medically unfit to fight by
the leading psychiatrist in the country
and i had millions of pounds millions of
dollars in um
lawyers fees to pay on ongoing battling
court cases
but i am so confident that i'm going to
come back and everything's going to be
swept away
the odds of me overcoming all them
obstacles never mind the weight and the
mental health
is like zero he it's not possible he
ain't coming back because
he can't from that day
i got my track suit on in the morning
and i was going to run two mile
i got about 200 yards and stopped
and i thought right i can't i can't run
i've run all my life i've always been a
very good runner
and i got 200 yards and i was totally
gone i could feel my belly moving on
it wasn't like a fat like jelly it was
like solid brick
it was it was a horrible feeling
i thought okay i'm gonna walk the rest
and i walked
and while i was walking i was on my
phone
and i saw a little video from deontay
wilder
and he said ha tyson fury let himself
down let his family down
he said he's that fat he'd never come
back he said and i'm glad he's gone
because i knocked him out anyway
just rambling on nonsense here
and i thought himself you know what i'm
gonna give it you proper
you're my motivation now i'm coming back
to get you
and and every day i'd go out on the
canal and i'd do a little running my
sweatsuit
and every day i get a little bit further
until i was doing four or five mile
again
consistently every day every single
i'm going to tell you something else
i've already won
because i agree win the fight or not on
december the first
i'm a winner oh i think that's one of
the greatest companies i've come back
from
every possible disadvantage
to being healthy i'm studying now 255
pounds in shape
in a mentally great place and i i feel
so great i've got a few marks on me
but i love it i'm in the rink's bar and
i'm struggling in the ring because it's
so much
not air but i'm i'm so happy that i'm in
there and i'm like
i'm back doing what i love to do now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best life 30 questions
of the day it's not enough to just watch
a video you have to
do something so pull out your worksheets
and answer these questions and if you
don't have the worksheets and you want
them for free check out the link in the
description below
question number one what does playing at
a bigger level look like for you
number two what specific steps do you
need to take to make it happen
and number three how will you find your
motivation consistently so it becomes
a habit and if you are doing the best
life 30 challenge with me put a hashtag
bestlife30 down in the comments below so
we can celebrate with you
chasing down your dream even if everyone
around you thinks you're crazy
is the only way you're gonna win i like
to say that everybody has michael jordan
level talent at something
everyone yes you you right there you you
could be
the greatest of all time at something
the problem is most of us settle for
something
just over survival something just good
enough to get by
instead of going for something that you
could be the greatest of all time
at the toughest choice i ever had to
make in my life was whether i should
become an entrepreneur
or go take this six-figure job traveling
around the world in investment banking
and i thought i wanted to be an
investment banker but i had this
thing client gnawing at me saying i need
to at least try this entrepreneurship
path just to test just to see nobody in
my family was an entrepreneur i didn't
have an upbringing of entrepreneurship i
didn't have
heroes or role models around me who are
entrepreneurs i wanted to model and be
like them
i thought i wanted to be a banker but
when this opportunity came up
i did not want to live with regret
that's the final
filter through which i made my decision
i looked at the two decisions
this is where you can't just make your
list when you're faced with a really
tough decision you have to make your big
decisions with your heart
and the small ones with the head what do
i do
the the most difficult decision in my
life what do i do do i take this job
or do i try to be an entrepreneur make
300
a month and have 30 of a company what's
that what's the best call
i did not want to live with regret
i asked myself if i'm 100 years old and
i'm sitting on a rocking chair
and i'm in a retirement home and and i'm
i'm about to go this is it this is the
end of my life when i look back on
this moment right now i look back on it
what will i regret more
saying no to the job or saying no to the
business
i thought you know what i can always get
another job i could it may not be the
same job it may not be in asia like this
one was
may not be traveling as much but i can
get another job that's similar
this business i don't know if i'm ever
gonna get the shot again i don't know if
i don't know if this will ever come
around again
i'm gonna regret it if i don't know and
i adopted a mentality that i would
rather
know and fail than not no i had to know
if you want to join the best life 30
challenge click the link right here
below me or if you want some more videos
to boost your motivation check out the
playlist right here next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there